[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a Europa hoy el
programa de actualidad Europea de France
24 en español yo soy Esther Herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en Bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy nos preguntamos está viviendo
Europa un auge de la extrema derecha
Cómo puede afectar a otros países la
victoria de Georgia melón y en Italia y
en sus relaciones con la Unión Europea
antes de pasar al debate hacemos una
pequeña panorámica de Cuál es la
presencia de los partidos de extrema
derecha en Europa
Francia Suecia Alemania Italia Finlandia
Bulgaria Hungría España son solo algunos
de los países en los que los partidos de
ultraderecha aumentaron su presencia en
algunos casos llegaron a ser clave en la
formación de gobierno Marín no ganó la
presidencia de Francia pero su partido
obtuvo 89 diputados en la asamblea
nacional un éxito sin precedentes para
el partido de extrema derecha en el país
galo el partido demócratas de Suecia
movimiento de ultraderecha es desde las
últimas elecciones una pieza clave en la
formación de gobierno en el país nórdico
también lo puede ser en Bulgaria
en Alemania afd ha ido aumentando en
presencia y es la cuarta fuerza en el
mundo está alemán sin embargo el
verdadero quebradero de cabeza para la
Unión Europea es Italia el partido
hermanos de Italia liderado por George
meloni defensora del papel del dictador
e ideólogo del fascismo Benito Mussolini
fue la fuerza más votada en las últimas
elecciones preocupan sus posiciones
contra los valores europeos y una
retórica anti inmigración que hace temer
mayores choques con Bruselas cada vez
más analistas admiten que lejos de ser
algo pasajero la extrema derecha volverá
a imponerse y a posicionarse en Europa
y para realizarlo tenemos con nosotros a
los eurodiputados Javier Moreno del
grupo social demócrata bienvenido Javier
gracias buenas
y con Antonio López del partido popular
europeo bienvenido Antonio Muchas
gracias a los dos por estar aquí me
gustaría primero de todo preguntaros en
los últimos años especialmente a raíz de
la crisis económica vemos que han
aumentado los partidos de extrema
derecha Por qué consideras que podría
calar más su discurso su discurso
últimamente Javier a ver la gente lo
está pasando mal primero con la pandemia
ahora con la crisis económica con la
inflación lo está pasando mal y ellos
tienen un discurso simplista lleno de
mentiras y eso es lo que permite ellos
juegan con el miedo el temor el malestar
de la gente y Lo tratan de
transformarlos en votos Y eso es lo que
hace nosotros tenemos que explicar que
ante esta
una situación tan difícil porque estamos
actuando los los gobiernos moderados y
europeístas
Antonio estás de acuerdo Yo creo que lo
que tenemos que empezar a delimitar es
quien realmente Es que yo creo que es
más que la extrema derecha son los
populismos en los cuales se engloba
tanto extremos de izquierda y derecha yo
creo que aquí estamos sentados
representantes de fuerzas
centradas de izquierda y derecha qué es
lo que ha dominado efectivamente el
panorama político y lo volver a hacer
siempre y cuando sepamos
democráticamente volver a recuperar la
confianza de aquellos que han votado
estas opciones que al final es humo y
paja no no realmente habla mucho siempre
están se sienten mucho más cómodos en la
oposición pero no en el gobierno de las
cosas que es el momento más complicado
no con lo cual ahora muchos de ellos
está demostrando gobiernos que han
estado en coalición no tanto extrema
derecha como extrema izquierda en
distintos países europeos se demuestra
que al final pues no no es la solución
mágica pero es responsabilidad nos
muestra los políticos de Centro devolver
esa confianza también a ciudadanos que
la han perdido y han querido optar por
opciones ya digo más de estas un poco
imaginativas no que al final no ofrecen
nada como son los populismos en general
ambos representadas no dos partidos más
tradicionales en el sentido de que no
estáis en ningún extremo del Arco
parlamentario Pero de alguna forma han
fallado los partidos tradicionales al
electorado para que vayan opciones más
extremas en una democracia siempre
evidentemente Oye si votan estas
opciones
muchas veces que alcanzan niveles
ridículos en sus propuestas en sus
alocuciones que lo único que intentan es
llegar a las emociones de la gente no
sin realmente esas soluciones Claro
evidentemente puedes decir Oye ha habido
fallos y es responsabilidad nuestra
estudiar bien como los denominados
políticos tradicionales que no somos más
que políticos que queremos el bienestar
de la sociedad con propuestas realmente
prácticas no estas soluciones falsas que
yo hablo desde el principio con estos
populistas nuestra posición es más
complicada pero sí ha hecho que en los
últimos años indudablemente haya una yo
creo que va a haber una revisión también
del planteamiento de los partidos y su
acercamiento a los ciudadanos está
cambiando todo el mundo de la
comunicación no por ejemplo hay una
Revolución en estos momentos operándose
con las nuevas tecnologías tenemos que
estar a la altura de las circunstancias
Javier Yo creo que es verdad que hay un
apoyo que ha incrementado pero hay que
combinarlo con la abstención tengamos en
cuenta la gente que no les ha apoyado
pero que se han quedado en casa que
hubiesen votado Pues a los partidos
tradicionales con lo cual vuelvo a
existir nosotros lo que tenemos que
hacer y lo decía tono llegar a la gente
Y explicarles lo que estamos haciendo Y
que ellos efectivamente ellos con
soluciones simplistas no se llega a
ninguna parte o sea hacen oposición todo
va pero soluciones prácticas y
verdaderas no Proponen Entonces nosotros
sí que tenemos que hacer un esfuerzo de
explicarle a la gente sobre todo en una
situación tan complicada como la que
estamos viviendo en estos momentos
tenemos que estar más con la gente de
explicarlo mejor porque ellos ellos si
gastan mucho en propaganda en mentiras y
y les funciona bastante O sea que
tenemos nosotros que hacer un esfuerzo
si me permites Añadir además los
ejemplos son muchos de que alguno de
estos extremos han llegado a un gobierno
en algunos casos en algún gobierno
europeo ninguno repite al final al final
siempre quedan neutralizados Pueden
seguir como opción política pero
evidentemente se descubre la realidad
Que es que en gobiernos son incapaces
Realmente de gestionar el futuro de la
gente que esto si lo hacemos los
llamados políticos tradicionales yo lo
asumo con orgullo Si eso es estar
centrado y trabajar en esta democracia
Europea de otra manera y digo volviendo
a recuperar la voluntad de estos
votantes de forma democrática pues ya me
tradicional y Pero estos partidos son
votados por una creciente población cada
vez más países hay que hacer un cordón
sanitario a ver en esta casa en el
parlamento europeo lo estamos haciendo Y
espero que continuemos luego en los
gobiernos nacionales y regionales una
cosa es tratar de hacer cordón sanitario
otra cosa es casarse con ellos y creo
que en el ámbito de la extrema derecha
es más una pregunta que hay que hacerle
al partido popular y a las fuerzas de
derechas porque nosotros obviamente
nunca haremos un gobierno de coalición
con la extrema derecha
Antonio Yo tampoco Me sentiría muy
cómodo pactando con opciones de extrema
izquierda como las que tenemos en estos
momentos también en algún país europeo
no y el tema derecha no
sinceramente vuelvo a mi discurso
inicial ni unos ni otros pero tampoco
sacarlos o sea es decir han sido votados
por la gente hay que también reconocer
el voto democrático de la gente lo que
tenemos que hacer más allá de los
cordones sanitarios es trabajar para
recuperar la confianza de esa gente que
la ha perdido en nosotros y en las
políticas centradas de gestión de un
gobierno democrático normal de la Europa
del siglo XXI
el partido hermanos de Italia obtuvo un
26% de los votos que fue en coalición
con otros dos partidos pero este partido
en concreto ha sido el más votado Cómo
puede afectar un gobierno liderado por
Georgia meloni en las relaciones con la
Unión Europea Javier a ver la Unión
Europea es un club que tiene reglas y
tenemos un camino por delante lo que sí
pueden hacer es frenar frenar en este
camino en este destino común que vamos a
compartir ahora bien tengamos en cuenta
Italia ha recibido 200.000 millones del
fondo de recuperación y creo que con las
cosas de comer no se juega O sea que yo
creo que va a tener que adaptarse a las
normas y entrar por donde quiere la
mayoría porque si no se va a quedar
aislada y Italia es un país importante y
la unión siempre ha actuado como una red
de seguridad recuerdo los años 2000
cuando el gobierno en el que estaba
heider el austriaco se fue un poco
hacia donde no tenía que ir y la unión
actuó como red de seguridad para traer a
centrar otra vez y seguir en el proyecto
común que compartimos los 27 países
Aunque Austria no es
italianos pero ella misma se dará cuenta
que aquí o juegas con los demás o hace
mucho frío fuera
ya gobernó Mateo salvini que era de un
partido
independentista nacionalista de extrema
derecha no en Italia de la liga y hoy
está el 8% Y entonces estaba al
veintipico por ciento no es decir yo me
calculo conociendo la política italiana
bastante bien participado numerosos
encuentros electorales apoyando ahí a
candidatos muchas veces de fuerzas de
Centro derecha debo decir que creo que
meloni
entiendo lo normal y Lógico es que al
final y sobre todo por las razones
expuestas por Javier lógicamente la
dependencia económica no los fondos
europeos etcétera pues van a hacer que
tenga un gobierno mucho más realista
otra cosa es que hará declaraciones pues
como les gusta a estos no en provocación
y tal de vez en cuando de Chulería de
enfrentamiento con Bruselas tal pero no
no creo que pase más en la praxis No
creo que pase de ahí si pasa entonces
tenemos un problema efectivamente pero
lógicamente tenemos que esperar a ver
qué es lo que el gobierno de melón y
ofrece
hay temores quizás de que pase algo como
ha ocurrido con con Hungría con Víctor
Urban que hemos visto cómo se ha ido
extremando su discurso hasta el punto de
que fue suspendido del partido popular
europeo su grupo Antonio puede ser está
la tendencia quizás Javier
hace muchos años dijo lo nacionalista o
sea el nacionalismo te lleva a la guerra
y yo creo que sobre todo los tiempos que
estamos viviendo con una una guerra de
Putin en nuestras fronteras con la
recuperación de la pandemia con la
inflación que tenemos yo creo que los
ciudadanos y ciudadanos se dan cuenta
que necesitamos cada día más Europa más
Europa que les llegue a su casa a sus
bolsillos y que les dé la oportunidad de
desarrollar su proyecto vital yo creo
que las propuestas que hacen Urban y
Ultra nacionalistas son una involución
en el desarrollo de nuestras sociedades
van a encontrar los derechos de las
mujeres en contra los Derechos Humanos
encontrar las minorías Son son digamos
no es el proyecto que nosotros y yo creo
que también el partido popular europeo
está defendiendo de seguir adelante en
un camino que llevamos recorriendo desde
hace décadas y no podemos ir para atrás
sobre todo tal y como está ahora la
situación en Europa y en el mundo yo
creo que tenemos que seguir adelante ya
como última pregunta a Antonio
comentabas que es muy importante que los
partidos tradicionales vuelvan a atraer
otra vez a este electorado pero estamos
en un momento de crisis muy complicado
en alta inflación la gente tiene
problemas para pagar sus facturas de la
electricidad y la extrema derecha puede
canalizar este miedo la extrema derecha
la extrema izquierda y todo lo que sea
populismos utilizarán cualquier
argumento siempre cualquier malestar de
la población pues para para para cometer
este tipo de actuaciones o como los
salvadores aquí de la patria o de lo que
haga falta pues lógicamente Pero esto no
es novedad Ahora yo entiendo que los
medios Ahora les gusta mucho los
titulares no y las sobre todo noticias
muy negativas amplificarlas tal si esto
ha existido y existe Y existirá Pues
aquí lo dejamos Muchísimas gracias
Antonio Javier a ustedes les esperamos
en el próximo programa de Europa hoy
Gracias por ver France 24 en español
[Música]